if you feel like you always have to have
a professional image and you have this
front up of what you allow people to see
I'm going to share with you a fun clip
from Martha Stewart in advertising that
you did for Arm and Hammer to show you
that if you can lighten up you're gonna
get more business for yourself I'm
working hard all day to be busy in the
kitchen cooking and makin for my videos
I need to leave this place looking clean
and fresh I'm Martha Stewart so it has
to be the best bring on the B string on
the clean this kitchen has to be ready
for the next big scene the fridge it's
filled with all my favorite food any
funky odors can really ruin my mood this
box here helps food taste fresher longer
stops any odors from getting stronger
after 30 days pour it down the sink and
your drain will be free of any gross
stink ding ding ding
add it to the dishwasher to absorb any
smell for those stinky sponges good so
call healthy counters and oven they need
a good cleaning and this channel pure
scrub will leave them green ahh
let me save one more time for all 6 year
free on Arm and Hammer baking soda bring
on the clean this kitchen is now ready
for the next big scene now if you think
about Martha Stewart you don't normally
associate rap with anything close to her
brand
she's the professional expert who you
look up to that you're gonna get solid
advice from to decorate your home or get
you great recipe ideas that you can take
home for family events and here she is
making this rap commercial that's going
public with Armand Hammer and what it
does is humanize her and makes her fun
and makes her more relatable and then
it's easier to connect to her and her
message you need to do the same thing in
your business you see so many
entrepreneurs are so wrapped up and
always having to be professional and
always put in on this image and that
you're perfect and infallible and you
have no flaws and what it does is puts
up this wall between you and your
customers and you may think that you're
doing the right thing by always seeming
professional and on top of things but
really you're making it harder for
people to connect with you look at my
youtube channel as an example if you go
back years you'll find that the advice
that I
given its almost the same advice that I
was giving five years ago right my
opinions haven't changed that much
my advice hasn't changed that much some
of the stories that I'm telling even
those haven't changed is those are still
some of my stories so why am i had so
much success in my channel now compared
to five years ago a big part of it is I
got more personal right if you look at
my videos they were professional
there's me Evan you know talking head
expert but there's no emotion in what
I'm saying I'm not sharing deep personal
stories I'm not sure anything that makes
me feel vulnerable I thought I always
had to be this professional expert who
looked great but now I may be sharing
personal videos I may be sharing my trip
to Disney World I may be sharing me
trying to learn something new and
sucking at it I may be sharing what I'm
doing during the day I'm hearing a lot
more personal content and allowing you
guys to see more of who I am and being
vulnerable like it or not and at first
it's scary at first you feel like you're
opening yourself up to so much criticism
and that people won't like you right you
feel like people will reject you but it
does the exact opposite where what it
does is it opens you up and it allows
people to come in and love you so much
more and feel connected to you and your
business so much more so take a look at
your website take a look at your social
media take a look at all your marketing
are you there is your passion coming
through is your deep story coming
through because the thing that's gonna
separate you from your big competitors
is your story why am I gonna buy from a
small entrepreneur instead of buying
from big trusted brand it's usually not
gonna be because of price because you
know they have economies of scale and
they have a reputation which you may not
have yet it's your passion right it's
your story I buy from entrepreneurs
while I love entrepreneurs but I buy
from entrepreneurs because I feel like
that entrepreneur cares more I feel like
if I hire you to cut my grass if I hire
you to make my website if I hire you to
deliver flowers you're gonna care more
because you're putting your heart and
soul into this business
we're the big companies the people who
work there they don't really care that
caring that personal relation is your
competitive advantage and if you're not
using that in all of your marketing
material then you're holding yourself
back so stop worrying about being so
professional start being more personal
more caring more yourself and you'll
have a lot more fun as well as make more
money believe thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to hear what you think
on this topic leave a comment below I'm
gonna join in the discussion have you
felt it difficult to share your story or
do you have an example of when you did
share something a little more personal
you had some great results leave in the
comments below I want to see what you
have to say and thank you again for
watching go out have a great day and
I'll see you soon